[MUSIC]
Thank you so much for being here.
>> Happy to do it.
>> We're thrilled to have you today.
Obviously, a lot of excitement here.
Let's just take a quick poll.
How many you use Uber?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Awesome.
>> That's like 100%.
>> I'm going to clap for you, thank you.
>> How many of you used Uber this week?
>> Nice.
>> That's like 80, 90, so
this feels like what our professors
are talking about when they
are teaching us about product market fit.
>> Now how many have used Uber Pool?
Wow, pretty good.
>> 75?
>> Yeah, it's great.
>> Pretty good!
So we have so much to talk about today,
I would love to start with Iran but
then eventually move on to IAC,
Allen and co, Expedia, Uber.
>> Sounds great.
>> Great, so starting from the beginning,
your family,
Seth was 7,500 miles aways from
here in the Bay Area in Iran.
And that's where you grew up running
a hugely successful conglomerate.
>> Yes.
>> In 1978,
you ended up having to flee, eventually
seeking asylum here in the United States.
>> Yeah.
>> When you got here,
you didn't speak fluent English?
Sometimes you introduced yourself as
Daryn Kay instead of Dara Khosrowshahi.
>> Those were dark days, yes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> How did the challenge of
assimilation shape you as a leader?
>> So I think, first of all,
I was a kid, I was nine years old.
And I think that children, as you know,
are much more flexible and
they can assimilate much more easily into
any situation, different situations.
But I was also the youngest brother, and
I was one of the younger
cousins in the family.
So I was very,
very low on the totem pole and
I had to assimilate even
before I came to the states.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Whatever was going on,
I had no say in the matter.
And coming to the states for us,
what we had was, we always had family.
And that was a constant and
is a constant for
me in that really I certainly was thrown
into a new environment but I always had
the protection of family to come home to.
We were very lucky to have a very
strong education in Iran, and
we continue to have a strong
education in the US.
I learned a lesson that if you don't
understand what someone is saying,
the answer is no, not yes,
because it's an Iranian thing,
you always want to say, yes.
So I'd have no idea what someone was
saying, I'd be like, yes, yes, and then
I'd be like playing football someplace,
having no idea how to catch a ball.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But for
me the assimilation that really
got us in was through sports.
Soccer was kind of the game of
the world and not so popular in the US,
so we were regarded at soccer
gods at my high school.
And that's how we got to
know a lot of other kids and
really assimilate it into the school.
>> Do you keep up with sports?
>> Yeah, absolutely, of course,
I'm a big Premiership soccer fan,
I wake up at 5:30 in the morning, my wife
says I'm crazy but she's good with hit.
>> [LAUGH] So
it's hard to know your personal identity,
you came here as a child and
you found your way.
It's also hard to know your
professional identity,
when you were at Allen and
Company, you met Barry Diller.
>> Yes, yes.
>> And he has a reputation where
some comment that he is demanding but
loyal,
you identified him as someone
you wanted as a mentor.
How did you know that, and what advice can
you give us on cultivating mentorship?
>> Yeah, sure.
He was my first true mentor, and
the way that I met him at Allen
& Company,
I was a young analyst working on a deal.
This was a hostile tender offer that Barry
had launched for Paramount Pictures.
He was running QVC,
there was a deal for Viacom,
which was is a big conglomerate,
to buy Paramount Pictures.
And Barry was really interested in the
combination of commerce and entertainment.
And when Paramount came in to play,
he went after it, and
I was an analyst on the deal, and
he's like this giant Hollywood mogul.
And this was a really dramatic
offer where we were making bids and
then they'd make bids, etc.
It was a very competitive
public battle for
control of this highly
strategic asset at the time.
And the thing that I remember about
Barry is, somehow he found out.
And he would deal with an SVP who
had a VP and an associate, and
somehow he found out that I
was running the deal model.
And I was on the trading floor,
just this nobody,
he found out that I was
running the deal model.
And he comes up to me, he's like, you're
the one running the deal model, right?
Yes, Mr. Diller, and he's like, okay,
I want you to explain to me exactly
how it works, and I said, when?
He said, right now, and of course
when Barry Diller says, right now,
you say, okay.
So I sat down with him and he wanted
to know everything about the deal model
from the person who had actually built it.
And he took the time and
I learned as I got to know Barry,
that one of the things that he really
believes in is going to the source.
That every time you get
information that is filtered,
you lose fidelity in the information.
This was a really important deal for him,
and he, instead of being comfortable
with someone who would present information
to him in a clean and comfortable way.
He wanted to be uncomfortable
with an unknown but
knowing that he'd be closer to the truth,
and that was how our relationship started.
And he would come to me on the deal model,
are we bidding to much,
are we bidding to little?
He was making the decisions but
he really wanted to go to the source and
understand the core of the subject matter.
We lost that battle, and
I still remember he released
a statement saying,
we lost, they won, next.
When I read that thing, I'm like,
I want to be a part of next.
So with that, we went after a bunch
of other deals and machinations.
And when the predecessor
company to IAC was born,
it was Home Shopping Network
at the the time.
He sold QVC,
took control of Home Shopping Network.
We closed on a very large deal to
buy an entertainment business,
Universal Television.
And at that point he said, well, I want
you to work exclusively as my deal person.
I said, I can't do that,
I've got a portfolio, he said, I want your
portfolio to be me, and I said, well then
give me a job, and he said, let's go.
So that's when I jumped
on board with him and
the one lesson that I learned
from Allen and Company.
Herbert Allen was the CEO at the time,
he always said that as an investor,
he didn't bet on companies,
he bet on people, he just said,
bet on people, I make my bet on people.
And I think one lesson for
me that I took away was, I was
an investor, I was an employee, right?
But instead of making a bet on the job or
instead of making a bet on the company,
I was making a bet on a person.
And I said, Barry Diller, this is
the person that I want to work with,
whatever you want me to do, I'll do it.
And I followed him and
it's been a great decision of my life.
He eventually sponsored you.
>> Yes, very much so.
>> And
tapped you to be the CEO of Expedia.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> And this was 14 years out of college.
>> I guess so, yeah,
must have been desperate.
>> Well, you proved yourself, right?
>> Yes, yes.
At Expedia, you grew the business
from 2 to $10 billion over 13 years,
that's very impressive.
At the same time your competitor,
Priceline,
they were a distant competitor at
the time you started being CEO.
And then eventually actually became the
leader in the online travel agency space.
>> Yes, it is very painful
even to hear you say it, yes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It grew to four times the size of
Expedia when you left.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Twist it in!
>> You had to so
many successes, I am curious
what you think your key wins were and
what you would have done differently.
>> I think I'll talk about
booking.com since, or
price, well is that booking
group since you brought it up.
This was a company that we looked at,
and Expedia was one of the big players
in the travel industry that was
growing incredibly quickly.
And we were taking on the offline travel
agents and the traditional players.
And what we saw with Booking.com was
a player who had very, very low margins.
And what prevented us from ultimately
competing with them the way that we should
have was that we didn't want to give
up our own fat markets, to be frank.
And it goes to the whole issue
of the innovator's dilemma.
We saw this business, and listen, we had
an opportunity to buy them just like
Priceline actually bought booking.com.
And booking.com became 95% of the business
and if we named the business booking.com,
we'd have the same opportunities
about our company.
But in looking at that company, our
team poo pooed it because it was a less,
the unit economics of that
model didn't look as good.
And instead of looking
at that as an asset,
our team looked at it as a liability.
And for me, that's a very important
lesson in that it's much easier for
a business to make all
the tough decisions.
And shape their business based on low
economics and low margins and then expand.
And expansion is inevitably faster if you
have a low price product, especially in
the Internet world where price is
something that is easily discoverable.
It's much easier to go from low margin and
expand than be a high margin player and
then slowly bring your margin down.
We did bring our margin down over a long
period of time but if I had to do
something quicker, I would've taken the
pain up front, I would've done it faster.
And I think that for us, as a company,
when we started taken that margin pain.
And when we started really rethinking
our business not as a travel company but
as a technology company.
That was the term that Expedia had to
go through to create value for us.
But it's absolutely a lesson learned,
which is, low margins are an asset,
they're not a liability.
And to lose that cost discipline
ultimately is going to cost you
market share over the long term.
>> When did you realize that, and
how quickly did you adapt at Expedia?
>> We realized it actually pretty quickly,
and the issue was that we had to
go from a situation where a transaction
was worth, call it 25% or 15%.
So we had to essentially engineer 40%
of our revenues out of the model.
And that was a process, it took us
a couple years to realize it and
then we started engineering it over
a period of two or three years.
What allowed us to engineer,
it was really making the bet on
our core technology platforms.
And for me, one of the toughest things
that I went through at Expedia was that
Expedia was a holding company,
a number of different brands
within the holding company.
And the largest part of the business
was Expedia.com, flagship,
full service online travel agency.
And I had failed twice in finding
a leader for that business.
Found a person, it didn't work out,
brought in another person,
it didn't work out.
And this was a particularly tough time for
me in the board, and
I went to the board and Barry.
I said, I've gotta bring in
another person, if I'm 0 for 3,
I think you should fire me,
Barry said, you're damn right.
So I said, then my third pick is going to
be me, I don't understand what it takes to
run this business, and the only way I'll
understand is if I run it for awhile.
So I was the CEO,
the corporate parent, and
then I was the CEO,
the operational CEO of Expedia.com.
And I learned more during those four,
five years when I ran Expedia.com
than I ever learned in my life.
And I learned what it really
means to operate a company.
I learned what it really means for
business and
technology to come together,
to really take risks,
to really accelerate the rate of
innovation within a company operationally.
And once we started turning
Expedia.com around,
the company overall
starting turning around.
And I was lucky enough then
to hand that business off to
the CTO of Expedia.com at the time,
who's still running that business.
So that was the real big turn, and for
me, it was a great learning opportunity.
And I know I would not be in this spot had
I not made the mistake of not being able
to find the right person
through on Expedia.com.
>> Moving on from Expedia, which-
>> From that painful loss to booking,
thank you.
>> Well, it's a win in the end, right?
2 to 10.
>> Yes.
>> In August, 2017, not too long ago, the
Uber board selected you to be their CEO.
>> Yes.
>> And I would presume that each of you,
the board and
yourself, had requests of each other.
Reportedly, Barry Diller,
helped you during this
three-week negotiation process.
>> Very much so, yeah.
>> It wasn't a negotiation process,
it was an interview process, really.
>> Okay, Either way, we can talk about
the negotiation or the interview.
But I'm most curious about
the negotiation and if you can offer us
any advice on negotiating job offers,
although on a much smaller scale?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, let me tell you.
>> So one of the advantages that I had in
approaching this role was that
I had a great job already.
And I loved what I was doing at Expedia,
and I really wasn't looking to jump ship.
And it was both part of
the interview process and
the negotiation process where,
during the interview process.
I was just dead honest about
what I brought to the table and
what I thought I needed in order
to succeed at the company.
And I still remember,
there was the various candidates,
and there were other candidates
who were much better known.
They were capital letters candidates,
they came in and presented to the board.
And I made a presentation
to the board where I
talked about my expectations of the board.
And part of the expectations for the board
were, what happens in the boardroom stays
in the boardroom,
doesn't get tweeted out someplace, right?
And also that with
the founders of the company
being very much a part of
the company spirit and
culture and what built that company.
If they really wanted a new
leader of that company,
it needed to be very clear
who their leader was.
And that I expected the board
to be there for me.
But I needed the freedom to
maneuver appropriately and
make changes that I felt
needed to be made quickly,
because this was a tough situation.
So I was very straight with
the board about those issues.
And I remember one of the board
members after the meeting said,
all of it was great but that page
was really, it was not such a great,
it was not that well
received by the board.
I said well, if it wasn't that
well received, then I'm glad,
because this is important to me.
And for whatever reason,
maybe they ignore that page.
But I just think that when you get
into a situation in a new opportunity,
or a new opportunity that presents itself,
being transparent about
your own capabilities.
And I think you've gotta go first.
And hopefully then getting
the transparency back from the other party
that you're talking about.
Ultimately, it's a win-win,
because you never want to get yourself in
a position where you're at the wrong job,
you don't have the capabilities, etc, and
vice versa, it's a loss for both party.
So I've taken this, one thing that
I've learned from Barry is he's
just the most transparent person on earth,
he just lays it out there.
I think Diane von Furstenberg was here,
and
I agree she was pretty transparent
about a lot of things.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Just,
it's part of that core
culture that he taught me.
It's something that I took to that board,
we have some very frank discussions
about expectations both ways.
And it's something that since
I've taken to the company.
I think in the second town
hall that we had as company,
I actually took my board presentation,
and I presented that at the all hands.
I said, this is me, this is actually
what I talked to the board about.
And it's the same deck, and
this is what you're going to get with me.
And then we go on from there.
>> As you said, it was a tough decision-
>> Yeah, very much so.
>> To move to Uber from Expedia,
you had a clear idea of what you wanted.
And one of our most sought-after
classes here at the GSB,
called Leadership Perspectives with
Joel Peterson and Charles O'Reilly,
we often ask visiting leaders
what winning is to them.
You traded the top job at Expedia,
where you were very happy and
just doing tremendous things,
for this job at Uber.
Which some of the press described
as a lose-lose situation.
>> I obviously wasn't reading that press,
but okay.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Ultimately, what is winning to you,
how did you think about that?
>> Honestly,
I wasn't thinking about winning.
I'll relate one story,
which was a funny story.
When I was first reached out for
the job by some headhunters,
I said, no way, I was happy where I was.
And then I was having a drink
with a friend of mine,
actually Daniel Ek,
the CEO of Spotify, at a conference.
And he asked me, he said,
have they reached out to you?
Because I told them,
I think you'd be perfect for this role.
I'd say yeah, but I'm happy,
I'm doing great at Expedia.
I'm not going to,
why would I ever do that?
And he looks at me and he says, Dara,
since when is life about happiness?
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] And he stared at me with his
Scandinavian eyes, and-
>> [LAUGH]
>> And he said,
it's about doing something great.
And my wife was there, Syd was there
as well, and she's like, come on,
man, you should go for this.
So between those two, that was kind of
the moment that that changed for me.
And listen, there are very few times in
your life when you can change the world.
Or you can change something
that's truly important.
And for me, the advice that I always give
folks that I talk to as far as careers is,
I think that people often optimize way too
much for the role or the company, etc.
The first thing that I always optimized
for is, who are you going to work with?
And the people that I met on that board,
even though there were questions
about the board, they were excellent,
the folks that I talked to on the board.
And the second and third are,
can you go to place where you
personally can make a difference?
And can you go to a place
that's making a difference?
I was in investment banking,
where I was making a difference, but
I didn't feel like the impact
on the world was quite there.
And this Uber opportunity for
me was, this is an extraordinary
opportunity to make an impact at a company
that's making an impact in the world.
And my attitude was,
it's not about winning or losing,
it's actually about taking a shot.
And if I took a shot and I won, then
glory come upon me, or whatever it is.
But even if I took a shot and
I failed, and
I don't plan to fail,
I took that fricking shot.
And when I'm 30 years from now, 40 years
from now, I'm going to have a great,
great story to tell my kids and
their kids and their kids.
That, to me, is the definition of winning,
winning is getting in the game,
is playing the game.
And for me, a big part of
winning is winning as a team,
I don't want to win alone.
It's so much more fun to
celebrate with teammates, it's so
much more fun to celebrate as a tribe,
as a family.
So for me winning is, I'm playing in
a game and it's a really important game.
And I've got a team around me, and
if we win, it's going to be a great story.
>> One of the central tenants you
mentioned was going to a place where you
can have impact.
>> Yeah.
>> To be sure, there was a lot
to do at Uber when you came on.
And in particular, Uber has gone through
hell because of accusations around Me Too,
unprofessional management, safety issues.
>> Yeah, deserved, in some.
>> The culture was thought to
over-index on this culture of
begging forgiveness
versus asking permission.
How did you address that specifically,
and what's left to do?
>> So I think first of all, the,
I don't know if the company,
well, I kind of know that the company
wouldn't have succeeded and
been in that positon in the first
place without that culture.
So I know that's it very to easy to
create a size it after the fact, etc.
But the fact is that there are very few
companies that have created the kind of
brand and the kind of service that
that team created in the world.
It was historic, it is historic,
it will be historic.
But the one thing that I've
learned is success imprints
much more forcefully than failure.
And what the pattern that you
see with companies is that,
anytime you have a success,
of course it's because of you and
everything that you do and
your culture, etc.
If there's a failure, it's the market,
or the market wasn't right,
timing wasn't right,
it's always someone else.
So success sometimes, and
the kind of success that Uber had,
was so extraordinary, that actually
in hindsight it kind of made sense.
The success was born out of aggression,
and going for it,
and not taking no for an answer,
and running through doors.
And it worked, and
it worked spectacularly,
but that hid Some negatives and
some very significant negatives that we're
forming as a result to that culture.
And I think that
I have an experience that kind of
success that Uber experience early on.
I don't know if I would have seen it
because they're too busy winning.
And they're too busy being on
the photo spread of a magazine
talking about how they're changing
the world and how they can do no wrong.
So I want to be careful about how we think
about this situation, where we wound up
was that once the winning stopped,
the fall was really, really tough.
And it happened suddenly.
And I think the company
hadn't built the bulwark and
the framework to be able to
resist the wall that they hit.
And they needed a change.
And I'm here and
I can be a part of that change.
That said, what we wound up with
was a culture that was, I think,
not diverse enough.
There was one way, and
there was the only way that was
defined kind of as a Uber way.
The company had not taking the time
to think about diversity of thought,
diversity of origin, gender diversity.
Thinking about under represented
minorities and their position
at the company, I think that the company
was a little bit too top down and
it's part of the power of
the founder like company but
it can also be part of the weakness
of the founder like company.
And I think these are all
actions that we're taking.
This is a company,
we are truly a global company.
The connection that we have with
the cities that we operate in,
we're not just the digital company.
The connection that we have with the
cities that we operate in are physical and
are fundamental.
When our payment system goes down,
we have drivers who don't get paid,
and some of them need to get paid in
order to afford dinner that night.
So the connection that we have for
the cities with our driver partners,
with our riders, are so fundamental and
so important that it's incredibly
important as we develop as company,
to be as diverse as the business the
riders and the drivers that we're serving.
To be diverse in our views,
in our international viewpoints, etc.
And we are working very hard in bringing
a leadership team that values that
diversity, and then pushing down the
culture of truly celebrating differences.
Truly being at one and in service of
the cities in which we operate, but
it's a journey, it's only been an year,
and it's a start, but it's something that
I and I think our leadership team
are incredibly passionate about.
And the opportunity for us is,
I think there's this dislocation
between technology companies and
the rest of the world, and
it's coming out in a lot of ways.
We're not the only tech company.
We're in some sense
the tip of the spear here.
Bu I think as a technology company,
we touch people in a way that
other tech companies don't.
It's fundamental, I think we're touching
the cities in which we operate.
So I think we can,
we as Uber, have the opportunity to be
that next generation technology leader.
Both in terms of culture, but
actually how we connect to the cities and
the constituencies that we work with and
operate around.
So it's a big job, but I'm psyched for it.
>> What's one specific example of a seed
that you're sowing right now that
could actually, ultimately look like what
you're describing as an ideal stunt?
>> We're thinking about
our driver-partners.
We've always called our
driver-partners partners, but
I don't think we've treated
them as such in the past.
So now when we are launching our product,
the driver app,
we actually go to our driver partners,
we do the research with them.
For the first time, really,
we got driver partner beta testers.
And go out there, and we actually build
not what we think they should have, but
actually what they're telling
us they should have as well.
So it's just a very different way of
building product than we've had in
the past.
One of the areas where
we're thinking about for
our driver partners are insurance.
It's what if they get in an accident,
maternity, paternity leave, etc.
We have partnered with AXA in Europe to
actually provide these kinds
of insurance coverages for
our driver partners and it's something
that's been incredibly well received.
So that might not have
been a direction that old
Uber would've gone through, but
I think that a more mature Uber, an Uber
that understands that our driver partners,
in many ways are the face of the company.
That's an area that we invest in,
and I think more and more,
we're looking to treat them as
the true partners that they are.
>> Look at the external side of the house.
There's a lot that you've been doing
internally, and you mentioned that another
one of your tenants is going to a place
that actually can have an impact, and
indeed, Uber has shown and
demonstrated that potential.
A former high-ranking Google executive
recently said to the New Yorker that,
quote, everyone is terrified of Uber.
Your comm-
>> Who is that person?
>> Anonymous New Yorker.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So your competition is gunning for you.
>> Yes, or course.
>> And one of our beloved lecturers here,
Rob Seigal, often asks and
popularized the following
question to visiting executives.
You have one silver bullet to
take out a competitor, who is it?
>> Wow-
>> [LAUGH]
>> That is a tough one.
A silver bullet to take out a competitor.
Might be a pink competitor, I'm not sure.
>> [LAUGH]
I honestly think that right now,
I actually do very much believe that
companies are too competitor focused
sometimes and many times stop caring about
whats important, which is the customer.
If there's a silver bullet for us,
it's actually really starting, and I
think Uber, we have been, to some extent,
historically too guilty of competitors and
what they're doing and share, etc.
We are now really, our operations
teams and our product teams and
our technology teams are working together
in a way that is customer-obsessed.
And our customers are the writers and
the drivers and that is,
if there's a silver bullet, I don't
want to shoot it at the competitor.
I actually want us to accelerate
this kind of new customer obsession
as a company because ultimately,
whether we win or lose,
it ain't going to be about
what the competitors do.
It's about what we do.
We have a global scope.
None of our competitors
have a global scope.
We are multi-product.
We've got a rides business that is
enormous and growing very quickly.
We have an incredibly
business growing with hits.
We are getting to scooters and bikes.
We're getting into vitove,
vertical take off landing products,
we're getting into frame, etc.
The definition of success we're
taking on so many competitors
that I need a silver shooting machine
gun to take out my competitors.
So it's really we've gotta be
focused internally in order to win.
That's the real focus for us.
>> Lots of product lines and
on top of that you're planning
on going public next year.
>> Yes.
>> We talked about this a little bit,
and specifically in the context of Uber,
how do you trade off
investing in growth or
in the new products with demonstrating
predictable profitability to shareholders?
>> We're not going to have
predictable profitability.
And we'll say it to our shareholders,
and the shareholders can choose.
If they want a predictably
profitable company, go buy a bank.
Don't come to us, simple.
>> I notice when you were
describing you're [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] [APPLAUSE]
>> I just, I'd rather be truthful.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I can't wait for
your shareholder letter.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I did have, when I was at Expedia,
I had a, I still remember an investor
meeting with an investor and
he talked for like 5 minutes
about being a long term investor.
We're a long term investor,
we're going to be an owner with you etc.
I'm like so what's your average holding
period and he looked at me in like,
with those deep eyes and
he said Nine months.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I was like, my god.
So it's just, you've got to,
there are true long term investors but
just like you can't be
too competitor focused,
just focus on the product,
state who you are.
And that comes with limits and I think you
will get investors that you deserve and
the markets that we're going after are so
big and
the position that we have is unique.
And by the way, we have lots of tough,
tough competition that we will find
investors who hopefully grew with us that,
that really the long
term is what we're after.
And what I like to talk to,
to my team about is,
I'm actually short-term inpatient.
I want the small ideas that take
a week and I'm long term patient,
I'll take the big ideas that take five
years, I don't like the in between.
And so if there's a small idea,
get it to me,
get it launched in a month,
get it launched in two weeks.
I'll take that,
I'll take the big long term bets.
Don't come to me with in between.
>> One thing when you were describing kind
of the product sweep that you're most
focused about that I noticed is that you
did not mention autonomous vehicles.
>> That's part of the ride-share business.
With autonomous, what's different
about us, as it relates to
other companies out there is Autonomous
is autonomy, means to an end.
Now, autonomous technology is going to be
incredibly exciting in terms of safety and
ultimately cost and
providing the services, transportation and
mobility service to everyone everywhere,
especially if you don't live
in the middle of the city.
But I don't believe that autonomous could
be commercialized at the giant scale
that it has a potential to do so
without ride sharing.
And I believe that any rideshare service
that doesn't have autonomous 15 to 20
years from now will exist.
So to us, autonomous and rideshare
ultimately are going to be one and
the same and the advantage that we have.
The magic is that we are able
to have them all under one roof.
When we develop autonomous, we can
develop it for a very small use case.
Which is let's say for
one percent, by the way,
that very small use case is going to be
very difficult, but one percent of routes,
then two percent of routes,
then three percent of routes.
The challenges that we have to take
on in commercialization are much,
much more simple than the challenges
that any autonomous-only player.
So for us, autonomous and ride share,
they're ultimately going to be one and
the same for us.
>> Do you think, on the supply side,
eventually Uber might serve as a platform
for players, right now, who are saying
they're autonomous only, like Waymo?
>> Very much so.
Yeah, we will welcome all comers,
and you'll see that now.
For example,
we have an integration with Lime.
They have bikes and scooters out there,
already I think they are live in Oakland.
So ultimately the vision that we see
of Uber is, we want to be that A to B
mobility and transportation platform for
people, food, and things.
And no one company can provide
all of the different versions of
transportation mobility.
We will look to integrate in all
other many many other third parties
just like Amazon has their own product and
third party merchant product and
we want part of that mobility
to be hopefully provided by
cities the bus service,
Metro service, etc.
We want to have all of that available
in Uber so that if you say,
I want to get to the city now, what is
the best way for you to get to the city?
And if the best way for you is to take
Caltrain, we will tell you exactly when
it's coming, we'll make payment perfect
and we will make it predictable
as far as you're having real time data and
hopefully at some point we will
introduce surged pricing in all
the other cool stuff that I we do.
>> A lot to do.
>> Yeah.
>> And I want to turn to you now,
I might understand that you even
commuting to the Bay area from Seattle
>> The commute has officially stopped.
>> Congratulations.
>> Yes, I have moved.
Thank you very much.
>> That's fabulous news.
>> Yes.
>> Internally at Uber, you are riding the
ship, while simultaneously preparing for
this IPO.
You're also managing
the pressure of internal leaks,
an all hands meeting was recently
leaked just a day or so ago.
>> Yes,
the leads has stopped until yesterday, so.
But you are working to
repair trust with an Uber.
>> Mm-hm.
>> How that's a lot of tension.
>> Yeah.
>> How do you maintain your sanity?
Who's your support system.
>> [LAUGH] I'd say my wife.
You know she's a I'd
say there two elements.
One is When you come from a family whose
lost everything and then rebuilt it.
It puts a perspective which
is I just kind of don't have
a fear of loss anymore because
I know I'm going to be ok.
So the leak did it suck yeah,
but are things getting better?
Much better.
And then when I get home and
you know I have dinner with my wife and
my kids it's all good, and
the next day I'll do my best.
And you know what I know I always
have with me is my family.
And what I know I will be true to
is really giving everything I have
to this opportunity because it
is an opportunity of a lifetime,
and I'm incredibly lucky
to be in this spot.
>> It's interesting because before
you came to Uber and Expedia,
you tried to travel to India.
Your Visa got denied.
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH] But-
>> Apparently I wasn't a big deal enough.
Uber, I got a visa like that.
It was amazing.
>> And not only that, but
you were meeting with Prime Minister Modi.
>> Yes.
>> And equally as CEO, you are making
deals on an international scale.
Liasing with governments like the UK.
In a world far after Uber, might we
one day see Secretary of State Dara?
>> [LAUGH].
I would be very fearful for
in the country in that case.
I have joked that my job is half CEO,
half politician in this New world.
But I'm busy with all
the politics right here.
I don't think I want to get
into more politics than that.
>> One last question before we let you go.
>> Sure.
>> All right.
We're going to do a quick lightning round.
>> Okay.
>> [LAUGH] I'm going to give you a prompt
you can respond with a word up to
a sentence.
>> Sounds good.
>> All right.
Fortnite or World of Warcraft?
>> World of Warcraft definitely.
I actually tried to have a date with
my wife in World of Warcraft, and
I was this gnome, and he can put in
these commands to dance for her.
She was an elf,
which compared to her, I am a gnome.
She didn't think it was that cool,
but still.
>> Steph or Lebron?
>> I gotta go with Steph, I mean I'm here.
Nine Inch Nails or Radiohead?
>> Radiohead, most definitely.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm a big Radiohead fan.
>> You're the youngest of three brothers,
as you've said.
>> Yes.
>> Kave or Murad?
>> [LAUGH]
>> You're really trying to start
with Booking.com, kicking our ass and
then pick between, you know,
the proper answer of
the young brother is Dara.
[LAUGH] I'm a youngest too, I can relate.
Pike Place Market or
Fairy Building Marketplace?
>> I gotta go with Pike Place for now.
Gotta love Seattle you know.
It's in the skin.
>> Profits or growth?
>> Growth.
>> iPhone or Android?
>> iPhone.
>> Lyft or taxicabs?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I will walk before I'll take a cab.
[LAUGH]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you very much, I appreciate it.
Thank you
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]